the movie opens up with the greatest
escape artist of all time Harry Houdini
standing on the edge of a bridge all
tied up with metal chains and ready to
jump in the background Houdini mentions
that while other people want to escape
from their hectic life he is always
trying to escape death performing risky
acts he then jumps off the bridge right
into the frozen lake while a huge crowd
of people watches on with amazement the
movie then Cuts back to 17 years ago
where Houdini arrives at a brothel-like
place with his wife Bess Houdini to
perform and entertain the audience there
however seeing the dilapidated and vile
state of the place Houdini changes his
mind and decides to walk out but best
asserts that they have no choice as
money is running out for them she then
announces to the people there that
Houdini is going to perform an act in
which he will escape from a closed trunk
while still being handcuffed While most
of the people are amused one of them
scoffs that anyone can do it as the
handcuffs they brought are fake but
Houdini who always has a backup plan
tells the audience that he will wear any
cuffs that are given to him surprisingly
the man who labeled their performance as
fake turns out to be a cop himself and
he throws some real handcuffs in front
of them at first Houdini gets nervous
because of the intense pressure but when
the cops put the cuffs on his hands he
gets riled up he then slowly turns away
and opens it using a pin-like thing
hidden in his belt this immediately
impresses the crowd including the cop
and all of them applaud him with respect
from that day onwards Houdini became
famous throughout America with the title
of best escape artist he started
performing several other shows escaping
from not only handcuffs but also from
metal chains wrapped around his body one
night Bess mentions that she wants to do
something else other than performing
shows but Houdini makes it clear that he
does not want to return to a normal life
instead he wants to be the best escape
artist in the world with this the scene
flashes back to several decades earlier
when Houdini and his brother Das are
looking at a Travel Group performing an
illusionary act Houdini is so intrigued
by the performance that he instantly
started dreaming of becoming a magician
and making a living out of it and with
the days passing by he learned Small
Tricks and earned some money from it
Houdini brings the money home to his
mother and makes her happy but his
father isn't really fond of Houdini
performing in public because of this he
leaves his house with his brother at an
early age and decides to do something on
his own together the Houdini Brothers
start to perform on the streets and
collect money to support their mother a
few years pass by and one day while
performing on the streets Houdini
notices his future partner Bess dancing
for a Performance Group he secretly
watches her perform and quickly Falls
for her beauty and elegance after the
ACT he approaches bass and asks her if
she would like to work with him to which
she accepts from that day onwards the
two get along very well and travel
around the world performing magic tricks
for renowned people Houdini's brother
Das who is still in the states tries to
copy his tricks to stay relevant however
Houdini doesn't like this and decides to
perform even riskier tricks which no one
can even dare replicate the scene then
shifts to 1896 where visit a popular
prison and asked the head Sheriff to
lock him up expectedly the sheriff
refuses mentioning that he can only lock
up criminals but when Houdini starts
making fun of their prison quality and
Bets a hundred dollars for the cause he
becomes enraged and agrees to do it here
we get to know that Houdini wants to do
this stunt as it would gain a lot of
publicity even without paying off the
newspapers meanwhile the sheriff locks
up Houdini pretty well and best gives
him a kiss before leaving the sheriff
suspects that she has transferred
something into his mouth but when he
checks he finds nothing after the coast
is clear Houdini pulls out a metal key
opener that he had swallowed after
kissing bass and uses it to escape the
prison as a result the media goes into a
frenzy and Houdini becomes famous
overnight the fans even start
recommending him to escape from bigger
and more secure prisons Houdini accepts
one of these challenges and arrives in
Chicago Illinois in the year 1900 to
perform a trick this time he is wrapped
with metal chains all over his body and
even his mouth is covered with a strap
suspecting that best pasta mckierly
earlier while kissing however to the
prison guard's dismay after only five
minutes of being locked up Houdini
escapes from the prison without leaving
any trace of himself behind after his
numerous prison escapes Houdini becomes
famous all over the globe by the names
the handcuffed king and the Breaker of
Chains Khaleesi one day Houdini can be
seen shopping for prop items in a shop
he meets the owner Jim Collins who seems
to know him very well and also claims to
have designed most of the items in the
shop Houdini is really impressed with
Jim's work including the one in which
the performer has to escape after
hanging upside down inside a box filled
with water after a few days Houdini and
best visit Jim at his Workshop where he
has created a model for the water
container act as soon as he sees the Box
Houdini hops into the container with the
aid of Jim's assistance to check for how
long he'll be able to stop his breathing
underwater he impressively stays still
for a few minutes and signals to be let
out but unfortunately when Jim and his
crew try to pull Houdini out the
rectangular box on top of the container
gets stuck horrifying every one around
fortunately Jim has an ax lying around
which he uses to shatter the container
and set Houdini free the scene then fast
forwards to the time where Houdini is
performing the water container act live
in front of a large audience he also
informs the audience that in case of
emergency he has the head of the fire
department office holding an ax to break
open the container Houdini then starts
performing the act with his legs trapped
in the rectangular box Jim is hosting
the show and he asks the assistants to
cover the container a few minutes pass
by but Houdini shows no movement so the
crowd starts getting anxious as a result
the head of the Chicago Fire Department
arrives there to break the container and
when he turns back he is revealed to be
none other than Houdini himself the
crowd Roars in astonishment as they have
never witnessed anything like this
before with Houdini's popularity
spreading all across the nation the
director of the U.S Secret Service
begins investigating him they believe
that Houdini is an illegal immigrant who
has been fooling people with useless
acts but fortunately before any
roadblocks appear Houdini is approached
by Sir William Melvin the head of the
British secret service MI5 William
modifies Houdini's place of birth from
Hungary to the U.S and in return asks
for secret information from the enemies
of the USA and the UK acting on the plan
Houdini heads to Germany and performs
for the great Kaiser family he
eventually blows their mind after
performing a nearly impossible bullet
catching magic trick following this
Houdini meets with Riley one of Williams
officers and provides him with some
secret information that he overheard
while being around the Kaisers Riley is
really impressed by the work and showers
heaps of Praise on him he then leaves
but not before giving Houdini a red book
containing Russian grammar setting him
up for the next mission a few days later
Houdini and his partner bass can be seen
performing for a prestigious and
Powerful family in Moscow Russia to win
their hearts Houdini cleverly plays a
game where he will fulfill their wishes
he makes them write down their wishes
and lets the daughter of the family pick
one it reads ring the Kremlin Bell
everyone laughs at the wish as the
Kremlin has not been rung in over a
hundred years but Houdini being Houdini
uses magic to create a small rope which
he lets the small girl tug and as soon
as she does so the Kremlin Bell starts
to ring leaving everyone in utter
disbelief they even bow their heads to
pay their respects I'm sure Houdini
would have preferred money but I guess a
head bow is cool the next day Houdini
meets William in London and provides him
with information about what the Russians
are up to William Praises his excellent
work and also inquires about how he was
able to ring the Kremlin Bell Houdini
reveals that everything was set up when
the little girl chose a wish he secretly
switched it with the one he had already
prepared and every time the girl tugged
on the Rope his assistant Jim who was
watching from afar shot the Kremlin Bell
with his sniper before departing William
tells Houdini that he now wants him to
go visit the German ambassador and
extract some useful information from
them the scene then shifts to Germany
where Houdini is performing a new trick
in front of the audience and the German
ambassador Jim mentions that Houdini is
locked inside the safe in which he has
only 10 minutes of breathing time
however in reality Houdini is not in the
safe but inside the ambassador's office
trying to find some important papers
unfortunately while he is snooping
around the place the Ambassador returns
to his office with a girl compelling
Houdini to hide inside the safe and to
make matters worse the Ambassador
notices the safe slightly ajar prompting
him to lock it properly Houdini despite
being an expert in opening locks starts
feeling the pressure as he's never been
inside a real safe before but with time
running out he remembers that he is
Harry Houdini the greatest showman that
the world has ever seen with this
motivation he starts counting the number
of locks present in the safe by
remembering the clicks he heard when the
Ambassador locked it and with only a few
minutes remaining he successfully opens
every single lock and gets out of the
safe back on the stage when Jim opens
the safe he finds it filled with several
10-year anniversary gifts for bass
meanwhile Houdini meets up with William
and hands him the documents before
entering the stage and thanking best for
being his partner and tolerating him for
the last 10 years however she doesn't
like the fake gesture she confronts
Houdini after the show and states that
he only cares about entertaining the
audience and nothing else one thing
leads to another and the two get into an
argument which results in Houdini
spending the night alone in the bathroom
the one thing Houdini can't escape is
the dog house one day Houdini and Jim
are watching a video performance of
Charlie Chaplin inside a theater Houdini
believes that Charlie's not doing
anything special but Jim tells him that
he's the new competition later at night
Houdini returns home and again argues
with Bass the latter urges Houdini to
quit risking his life but he mentions
that he enjoys putting people in
confusion and emerging alive as the two
continue discussing Houdini notices a
glass filled with ice and decides to use
it in his next track he then rushes to
the bathroom and calls Jim to bring
buckets full of ice and pour them into
the tub after this he lies inside the
bathtub filled with ice practicing for
his next stunt a few days later Houdini
can be seen standing on the edge of a
bridge with his hands tied by metal
chains ready to jump inside a pool of
Frozen water the scene is the same one
from the start of the movie after
Houdini jumps Bess gets frightened and
anxious but to her and everyone else's
Delight Houdini manages to unlock his
metal chains and handcuffs underwater in
only a matter of minutes however just
when it seems the performance is over
Houdini is Swept Away by the water
currents he struggles for a while trying
to find a way out until he envisions his
mother there and with her help and
guidance he safely escapes the frozen
water seeing her husband risking his
life to the bits every time he performs
his stunts bass again argues with him at
home at first Houdini gets angry and
walks away but later he returns home and
apologizes to her for overreacting he
also agrees to do only safe acts from
now on following this during the next
ACT Houdini does not risk his life and
makes an elephant disappear Into Thin
Air surprising the audience after the
performance he is approached by the
British agent from earlier Riley who
asks him to visit Europe and Washington
to bring some secret information for
them Houdini tries to decline the
request but Riley convinces him by
saying that his fans will love a world
tour the scene then shifts to the Empire
Theater in 1914 where Sir Arthur the
writer of Sherlock Holmes is also
amongst the audience as he watches with
eagerness Houdini performs an act of
walking through a brick wall surprising
everyone after the performance Arthur
approaches Houdini in person and Praises
him for his Great ACT unfortunately as
soon as Arthur leaves Jim meets Houdini
and handsome a telegram Houdini reads
the letter which is from his brother
informing him of their mother's death
with the news Houdini is devastated and
collapses on the floor bass rushes to
him and Carries him on her lap after
Houdini calms down a bit he requests
best stop his brother from burying his
mother until he arrives for the funeral
in the next scene Houdini can be seen at
his mother's funeral where Jim inquires
if he can contact her using his
Supernatural power that he performed in
one of his acts before however Houdini
clears that the Act was merely a trek to
entertain the audience and that he
possesses no Supernatural ability after
the tragedy Houdini's Persona completely
changes he starts getting more involved
in movies but every day day he imagines
contacting his mother using Divine
Powers he tries contacting several
clairvoyants who claim that they can
contact the spirits of dead people
however all of them turn out to be phony
enraged Houdini exposes them and even
writes a book about them in 1925 A.D one
day Houdini again meets Sir Arthur and
his wife lady Doyle the latter who
claims to be a clairvoyant lady Doyle
asserts that she can make him contact
his mother and prepares for a personal
sitting with him at the same time a
fortune teller arrives and when Houdini
asks her to tell his fortune she reads
his palm and predicts that he will die
soon thanks for that here's five bucks
afterward Houdini is with the doyle
couple preparing to summon his mother's
Spirit lady Doyle picks a pencil and
writes something on a piece of paper
supposedly under the influence of
Houdini's mother's Spirit following the
procedure Houdini becomes happy and
thanks lady Doyle for contacting his
mother unfortunately when Houdini
examines the texts written by Lady Doyle
he finds them to be fake he finds clear
English writing in the text while his
mother couldn't even speak a word of the
language he also tells Jim that it was
his birthday that day and that his
mother would never forget that with this
proof he declares that lady Doyle is
fake and exposes her and Sir Arthur via
radio programs and newspaper interviews
he also declares that he will provide 25
000 to anyone who can make actual
contact with his dead mother in 1926
Houdini visits Boston Massachusetts to
meet a notorious Clairvoyant who calls
herself Marjorie he attends one of her
table sessions and exposes her fakeness
enraged Marjorie visits Houdini and his
hotel room and tries to seduce him but
to no success hence before leaving she
reminds Houdini that he will die soon
and after that they will own his Spirit
Houdini's next show is scheduled in
Detroit Michigan where he performs the
act of escaping a rectangular box filled
with water Houdini has performed the act
on several occasions but this time he
ends up fracturing his ankle after the
performance a doctor visits him and asks
him to take a rest but Houdini responds
that he cannot miss his show and hence
decides to continue performing with with
a broken ankle later while Houdini is
with his fans a guy approaches him and
punches him hard in the stomach for
speaking against lady Doyle Houdini
whimpers in pain but doesn't talk about
it to Bess or Jim and simply goes to
perform his next show unfortunately as
he is addressing the audience he
suddenly collapses prompting Jim to
immediately call an ambulance at the
hospital the doctors open up Houdini and
to discover that he has a ruptured
appendix and that he has very little
chance of survival one of the doctors
approaches Houdini and breaks the bad
news to him he also talks about how
Houdini is a great performer who made
millions of people forget their misery
on the other hand Bess and Jim also
learn about the news and become
devastated and in no time the news
spreads like wildfire and best receives
a number of letters expressing concerns
about Houdini's health condition the
kind gestures move her and she finally
realizes the happiness her husband
brought to millions of people all around
the world unfortunately Houdini dies at
the early age of 52 while visioning his
mother in one of the nurses who looked
after him the whole world Mourns over
the death of The Great Houdini the movie
ends with Reverend Arthur Ford the first
spiritualist in the Church of New York
inviting Mrs Houdini for one of their
sessions to try and make contact with
Harry Houdini subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching